what people don't realize that don't
have businesses is for entrepreneurs
that own a business it's the fifth kid
it's the second kid it's a kid a
business is a kid it really is you
really love it like that when you're a
pure bread entrepreneur you love it you
do you don't want it to get hurt you
don't want it to die like you really
care for it like that attention is the
number one asset vayer Nation how are
you I'm super excited for podcast With
Friends number six I missed number five
um I I don't know how I missed that
which is my favorite number by the way
that's why I always do this my photos I
wanted to make a big to-do about it but
first I want to give a big shout out to
everybody on Twitch thank you for
joining big shout out to firsttime
chatter um hworld we've got three great
uh guests here I'm going to do what I
always do and allow them to go around
the horn and introduce themselves and
then we will just talk about some [__]
and then we will all go on our merry way
but most of all we're trying to provide
you as much value out there and my
favorite part is um we started a little
bit late cuz I had a client thing I hope
the three of you got it to talk a little
bit together but what's been going on
already just six episodes in I had two
or three people that have been on prior
episodes tell me that they became
friendly with the people around their
table that is my purpose besides making
sure you the audience everybody gets to
discover different people doing cool
things in the world so that we can take
this process that I love of strangers
become acquaintances acquaintances
become friends and Friends become family
so that's the goal that's the agenda
boys and girls and let's like always
start with ladies first uh why don't you
tell everybody who you are and what you
do well I'm Valentina Ferrer I'm from
Argentina I have a mother Wellness cycle
the name is kower because we teach
people how to have like a healthy
lifestyle and enjoying it we have like
matcha hialuronic acid in powder
everything is glutenfree and vegan I
love it and how long have you been doing
that from 2019 I start in during the
quarantine uh after I get pregnant so I
may make my time to really work at home
making everything uh my business partner
is from Australia so we start producing
in Australia and also here in US did you
know her him prior did you find him
during that time so my thing is
like always my dream was to have my own
business to work at home because I want
to be a mom a present mom but I need to
work I love work like for me it's like I
will I I was here looking and I was like
okay look what he have there hm or is
curious yeah like Curious always
creating business I used to put papers
all around my apartment and create so
much business I create mask for the face
I like one day I come home to Argentina
and I told my mom like Mom I'm buying
the salsa Valentina from Mexico and I'm
putting all the countries and my mom was
like what you know like always my mind
like that so
did you have did any of your parents or
grandparents have the entrepreneurial
Spirit my mom is a teacher okay and my
dad used to sell vegetables and fruits
so now I'm from the mountains with
horses like at my 17s I decide to take a
bath to buir the city I never been in a
city prior to that I didn't know how to
cross the huge
streets so for me I was like okay I'm
ready I go you were a country girl like
running like was crazy like Frogger like
the first time I I take a flight was at
my 20 years wow and I AR in Miami and I
told my mom I can't do like that to
watch you know the new icon building
yeah for me was crazy it's cool I
couldn't believe it's cool it's like
people first time there in New York feel
like it's cool I don't have that
background but but it was in you yeah my
my personality my spirit made me like go
travel and open my mind and and always
my family made me feel free and didn't
really expect nothing from me so that
made me like okay I do it because if not
toen I don't give a [__] no expectations
I love that I'm glad you're on the show
my man um so my name is Marvin Douglas
I'm from take the mic in oh sorry no
worries brother you can move it around
as much as you want it's name is Marvin
Douglas I'm from La um my family is from
El Salvador I do fine jewelry and
styling like fashion styling um
also working on like other projects too
like a kind of clothing jewelry brand
called father of pearl um and yeah I
mean
I I guess like how I started was my
grandmother did jewelry okay so she like
bought and resold jewelry and with that
she was able to bring my dad and like
call his brothers and all that to the
United States so she came over to the US
yeah she came over to the US and uh and
she flipped jewelry she flipped jewelry
she was kind of like is she alive yes
she is okay can you call her real quick
because I prefer Herby sitting in the
seat because anyone who flipped [__] to
get their family to the new country it's
crazy no it's inspiring as where does
she live she lives in the United States
now but I think she's in El Salvador at
the moment got it but she lives in La
usually or yeah will she would she come
to New York or is that going to be too
hard I'm being dead she could do it
brother I'm being dead she speaks
English no should I learn Spanish before
we have can we I wonder if we should do
an episode where I just translate in the
app no it's completely like I'll be
honest with you I'm I'm about to do this
podcast with from a with a retirement
home Community like I'm I am so hot on
this my team knows where I'm about to go
I believe in our Obsession of Youth
which is lovely we all want to live
that's great look good feel good live a
healthy life great but in our obsession
with youth culture I think America more
than any other place has completely lost
their respect for their Elders AB we
kids on a pedestal technology youth
culture everyone wants to look good and
we've systematically in the last 30
years we weren't great at it 30 years
ago in America right you know now I was
born in the USSR like you know obviously
we've got an immigrant crew at this
table like most immigrant families have
real [__] respect for their Elders
there wasn't even an option yeah America
historically has not been remarkable at
that it's not been the DNA no and by the
way before anybody gets upset I'm not
saying Americans don't like plenty do
but I'm talking in Net score Americans
hate I'll tell you right now I think no
one here's confused it's ins I'm seeing
[__] out there like I see people not
standing up for like grandmas at
airports we make we make fun of them
because they don't know how to use the
new apps kids are completely dismissive
of the grandparents right now like you
don't get it we've lost our way and I'm
obsessed right now with talking more
about us needing as a society all these
22y olds that are lost they could use
some more 80-year-old Friends real talk
so anyway if you can talk to grams tell
her Gary ve wants her on the show that
would be amazing I mean she would love
that honestly I might bring you back and
have you translate it with me cuz I
think we I think the world needs to hear
her she came to America flipped [__]
jewelry to get her family over I [__]
that's my f that's what I love flipping
and I would say she's probably the most
successful person in my family and it's
all her well I promise you she's the
most successful because when we redefine
success which is another goal of mine
when we redefine success from just money
and things to
impact of course she's the most
successful regardless you can build a
billion dollar brand and flip it to lbmh
which I hope for you she's still in my
mind going to be the most successful
because of what she put down I agree
think about what she did I agree that
effort just like you Chang your family
like what you did no but it's real it's
real talk my family the first time came
from us was because of you that's insane
yeah so Grahams did that she did that
she kind of you were born where yeah I
was born in Los Angeles and what kind of
kid were you I was like a
dick K I'm kidding I'm kidding I was
probably a no I was just like a really
like quiet observant kid um like my mom
even thought I had I apologize I'm going
this is going to be a really good show
and I forgot to tweet it out so you keep
talking I'm just want to apologize yeah
I was a really um quiet observant kid um
my mom even took me to the doctors to
get like checked out she's like you
don't like he doesn't talk he doesn't
cry like I'll sit him there he falls
over and he just kind of stays were you
do you feel like because you were just
you were in the middle you were too high
always um I'm still like very observant
you know and it's like now I just I can
talk
um outside of being a baby but um it was
just always like a like like how you
said like a curiosity kind of towards
the world you know and everything and I
think that's why I watch that's why I
look around so much um I'm always
staring observing and that's kind of the
kid I was but the work ethic too um I
think being Latino too um I was working
from like the day I started walking I
feel like like I was a little kid
cleaning houses with my mom and like
such a big just always yeah just always
doing like the weirdest jobs I was
working like at Six Flags when I was
like 14 years old and like look brother
I swear to God my my my biggest belief
in life biggest belief is that adversity
is the foundation of success yeah you
know what has become incredibly clear to
me when I read my 10,000 DMS a month
from the kids is the kids thatw grew up
with less that had to do the [__] that
we all did have an advantage yeah they
don't they don't see it then they think
they're friends that are wealthier and
all this they don't see it yeah they
they they they have the advantage of
what is being built inside of them that
really helps them because I think the
disadvantage by the way I've changed my
tune on this 10 years ago I didn't have
as thoughtful of a thought on this I
know unlimited kids that have wealth
that their parents did a good job and
they they had the right DNA and they did
a good job they they weren't entitled
their parents didn't buy them everything
they had jobs even though they didn't
have to like even if they flew private
like they understood that this was a
blessing and they grew up very but many
people like it's very hard to be hungry
when you're fed yeah and so you know and
then what happens that I never knew
growing up and now I have the privy to
all this information is it it it creates
enormous insecurity in a lot of these
kids absolutely and so you know we're
lucky like and you're lucky that you had
to you know shovel snow well in La you
didn't have to shovel snow you had a
vacuum rugs I grew up in a city outside
of La called Palmdale it's like the
ghetto desert so of course snow
is and all that I kind of people don't
know how the desert works it was almost
like a desert Farm it was weird yeah we
had chickens and geese and and so you
feel you feel like that work ethic
completely yeah found the moment I mean
when you're going through it it sucks
obviously
older and you gone through what you gone
through and you're so thankful for it
cuz you know it made who you are today
we'll get to more of your both of your
stories in a minute got to make sure my
man here to the left gets in well I'm a
nepo baby okay no I'm just
kidding I'm Dustin Kel and um I'm a
artist designer
entrepreneur uh I got into the business
um through working at um athletic
basketball companies yep and it was
always my dream to kind of design shoes
and that was kind of my way in so then
after going to college and getting a job
for that I uh I ended up starting my own
company um and then now I have another
company called trophy hunting which
is basically
the um it's a it's a brand about sorry
no worries nervous don't be nervous
brother honestly it's like this is like
literally when I say the chillest watch
this the the amount of love you're about
to get like there might not be a Kinder
Community honestly it's when when I die
this community will be the thing besides
my children will be the thing I'm most
proud of like you have to impress no one
yeah you don't have to worry about
anyone's [__] judgment definitely not
mine no now you know what it ISE tell me
this is important I like this the reason
the reason why I get nervous is is
really the script it's like I know who I
am I know what I do I'm pretty
accomplished and I don't like talking
about myself and I think I have a hard
time posing that as an answer to
something like I'm very good in
conversation and talking about what I do
and it it does take me a while to warm
up but you know I've worked I worked at
Nike stood in front of 150 people and
had to talk about like what I do and I
know about the city and all this I know
about you bro and that's where I get
kind of rolling but it's it's always
funny like I've always had this like
fear of of of talking about myself now
do you think your parents instilled that
in you um as like a good virtue cuz it's
a great virtue my parents were extremely
supportive like almost too supportive
but I was I was pretty I I picked up
things really easily so I was really
good at sports I always made all the
allstar teams I played baseball at like
a really high level I got a scholarship
to go to art school so it's like I had
all of these things kind of going for me
so it was the challenges that like were
tough so you know starting a business
was like my first real challenge where
you kind of get to a point where you
can't make like your talent just doesn't
win for you it's all the other things
it's speaking in public it's getting uh
meeting with people um telling someone
they can't do something well it's all
you know to your point it is your talent
like do you I understand what you're
saying your creative Talent or your
physical Talent or your intellect
you're right the reason business is so
cool is a it's super hard almost
everybody fails this is kids first of
all I know there's a lot more people on
uh just want to give a huge shout out I
know a lot of you are incredibly
generous on Twitch and give out uh gift
subs and I know a bunch of you are
coming over right now from text and from
my other platforms so if you're a first
timer listening in please uh say what's
up and say you're a first- timer and
tell me where you came from but back to
you brother like you know what's
interesting is it is your talent to your
point the last thing you said having the
ability to deliver cander to employees
where it doesn't scare them or upset
them is the most important trait of a
leader mhm yeah right it's hard for all
of us we've all gone through that right
number two like talking about yourself
or it that's called PR that's called
awareness it's called branding like I
get it like you know what happens after
being a superstar in big organization
versus being in the front is you're not
sitting on the shoulders of 50 years of
good work from Nike right I remind all
my friends that leave these big you know
my agency works with big companies and a
lot of times they think about jumping to
the real world as I tell them and
they're like I'm GNA do this look what
I've done at you know I'll use an
example of somebody we don't work with
look what I've done at BMW I'm like I'm
like I'm gonna do this I'm like real
quick you're standing on a 100 years of
good work by
BMW the to have play a factor it is the
factor now it takes skill to navigate a
big you know you got to know politics
and like you got to get [__] done in a
big organization it's a different skill
the problem in what we're all doing is
it's you and the bear the market is the
bear like there's no hiding no and also
you don't even for in my case I don't
even have a team you know I'm growing my
team that that is the other thing how
you know that you need someone that
knows something that you don't know how
you hire them it's right it's not right
you can follow is
like everything yeah it's it's and the
scariest part is when you say it's
different it's just different at this
moment for every one of us we we started
at zero when I started this company the
man standing right behind you Mike Boyd
was a college friend of my brother
AJ's he he literally he literally slept
in the office this is how ghetto we were
and we didn't pay for that office we
Bartered it because I didn't have money
to pay for an office and so like you
know everything's there's not a company
we know that didn't start at zero Apple
started in a
shed it started in a [__] shed let me
say it one more time for all the kids
that are listening and everybody
listening at home in a podcast Apple you
know that3 trillion doll Company Steve
and Steve started the [__] company in
a [__] garage in California they just
did it's just the way it is and so
that's [__] remarkable but you're
right that Talent is a different game
and it's a different Talent it is and
that's why you know like I also working
at bigger companies it's like I learned
that I I felt like I knew what I wanted
to do and I was having a hard like not
having a hard time I was I didn't enjoy
having to explain why you wanted to do
something I like doing the actual work
so that's kind of like why I moved to
doing it on my own or with with friends
and partners along the way cuz it's it's
really about working with friends doing
something that we love having the
freedom to do it when where wherever
yeah instead of going to meetings that
are about nothing exactly yeah and it's
like you know it's great it's like a
highlight reel of
um like support but for the most part
it's like I enjoy doing the actual work
I love it quick shout out to everybody
on Twitch I see a lot of you coming on
please make sure you sub up and also for
all you uh generous ones out there oh
did Corso gift five people a
sub is that what Corso did up there is
that the rules of that course so if you
did I love you for that all right what's
the biggest challenge right now in your
life professionally or personally that
you're willing to share because I think
one thing that I spent a lot of time on
is people see us in our current state
mhm and we all were in different states
and you know they just think this is
super great and yet I know all three of
you me included all four of us have
plenty of [__] that we're [__] wored
about that sucks that's really tough so
just to get on the V vulnerability train
for a second if I asked you obviously
this is a very public setting so you may
not go to the actual number one thing
which I think is incredibly appropriate
But whichever one you're closest to that
you're willing to share on what's the
thing that's most challenging right now
please for me the more challenge is like
I'm a mom and how old is two two years
old so my office is in the house oh
that's fun
so I I I love you know I I have working
with him my my biggest challenge is like
I have the company I also do modeling
yes of course I have my husband and
everything so all that how but he should
be like fourth right he's like a distant
forth he is but I got a trouble with him
I gotta go with him and I'm like you're
not coming I'm like no I have this I
have this meeting I got a travel that I
have that event of the brand Rio like
everything so for me is I wake up 6:00
a.m. and my day is 9:00 p.m. because I
work also with Australia and it's not
ending at 6:00 p.m. start my meetings in
Australia how do you
recharge walking love that every day
yeah every day for me I walk in my I
start and I know myself I can be mad I
can be feeling like [__] but after my 30
minutes walking I'm in another person do
you bre do you do breath work while
you're walking I walk that fast that I'm
like yeah mhm I don't know
with the baby or solo um I try to go
solo my moment as you should so I always
put Rio here Rio goes to preschool
because I want him to be with kids here
in New York you have an apartment y you
don't interact every day with kids so I
put him he love that he says like Mom
love you see you independent and that
are my three hours you crushed those
three yeah that 3 hour so for you it's
balancing the the little guy the
business the husband and your and your
career as a model and spokesperson
exactly that is one thing and my other
thing is like a grow so fast so my other
thing is like I was saying I need to
hire people and I I don't know like we
we should by the way after this podcast
we should talk I know so many people I
just mentioned them these people in cpg
brands at the biggest companies in the
world a lot of them are ready for next I
met with somebody yesterday I'm going to
introduce you to that I liked a lot like
yeah I'll help you like you know I was
like I came here and also want to listen
to you that's why I'm like I want to
like listen learn I'm learning here
we're all learning my man what's the
toughest thing right now real talk I can
kind of relate to you which is like um
kind of like the struggle of like kind
of balancing all these different things
that we have in our life and I'm sure
it's even harder with a kid like that's
like adding a whole another Factor yeah
because the love you have for them is
like different like like but what people
don't realize that don't have businesses
is for entrepreneurs that own a buiness
business it's the fifth kid it's the
second kid it's a kid yeah a business is
a kid it really is you really love it
like that when you're a pure bread
entrepreneur you love it you do you
don't want it to get hurt you don't want
it to die you don't like you really care
for it like that that's true and then um
with my businesses I feel like in a way
those are my kids right now you know and
it's like if I neglect one the other one
doesn't get the attention it deserves
and um that's kind of been a struggle
with me is that like with like the two
main businesses in my life both have
been
brought a lot of success into my life
and I feel like the more I focus on one
like it takes away from the other so I
kind of like I'm who do you think who's
the judge of that though it's you know
when I hear that yeah bro that's why I'm
jumping on this I want to help you and
I'm hoping this helps other people
online by the way I heard somebody just
say I feel like Gary Vibes best when
he's on other people's podcast I agree
with that I I enjoy more Q&A but I'll do
the best I can here so I apologize um
wow I don't think it was coming from a
bad place but I caught it late but but I
actually agree with it so I just wanted
to give love cuz I want to keep the chat
engaged by the way if you're listening
on the podcast go to Gary
ve.com twitch we are live streaming on
Twitch all of the podcast with friends
in real time so you can be part of the
show and two I don't know if some of you
have noticed I'm starting to just live
stream on Twitch me sitting in the
office and working all day which has
been a wild ASMR like people working
along with me sometimes I am mute and
talk so for everybody who's listening if
you want to work with me me during the
day work along with me start checking
out twitch make sure you
subscribe brother I got to say something
to you that I hope helps all three of
you but more importantly helps everybody
listening the only per people when they
ask me like Gary how do you how do you
deal with work life balance who's the
judge and jury of work life
balance you what are we going to look at
each other's what what are we looking at
each other's calendars and being like
you're like of course we're all worried
about one day getting older and having
our kids say you didn't spend enough
time with me you're like oh [__] that's
like the scariest or or your friend
saying like yo what the [__] like none
of us want to Big Time our friends right
that's a thing to worry especially when
you're younger like when you're really
focused on your [__] your friends are
like yo let's go out you're like I'm on
my [__] yeah and like oh now you're on
your [__] you don't [__] especially
when you come from the dirt and seem
like all four us like you know like this
no one wants to be a sellout and then
there's there's always your parents your
siblings like it's it's a big stress for
me that I play sympatico with my family
everyone knows I'm about them and I'm
always available but I stress and like
do they feel like I'm attached enough
because I'm moving yeah and like I worry
about that you know and like like like
but I always am reminded and I I talk to
myself everything I talk about in my
content or in this is [__] I talk to
myself
about and so like you're the judge and
the jury when you when you have when
you're married there's another person
involved in that then your kids become
involved in that your family your
friends but that's solvable
stunningly with communication and then I
think the other thing is like creating
some random things that work like always
doing a first Tuesday of every month
dinner with 12 people and mixing it if
you're the most extreme busy and I'm in
that camp yeah things like having a
standing reservation for eight the
second Tuesday of every month or if you
travel a lot like I do just like booking
it 30 days out to the best of your
ability and inviting friends family
acquaintances work friends and just like
you can hack it yeah it's just like
working out or skin regimen like there's
a way to make your time management
better I'll give you one most of my
meetings are 15
minutes almost everyone I know has 1
hour meetings that are complete [__]
yeah it's a 17-minute meeting but you
make it an
hour but if you don't have time make
more 15minute meetings but most of all
that's tactical
macro bro don't judge yourself yeah I
think that's what I'm pretty bad on
exactly that's my struggle youo no I I I
agree 100% with that because I think one
of the things that I'm lucky to myself
now that I figured that out the work
life balance because it is personal and
I I figured out that you know I like
having my hands in multiple things so
I'm just aware of that so I I draw all
the time and do art just for me and
don't get commissioned out or anything
so no one could tell me what to do I'm
still entrepreneur and I and I still
have to hustle but I also still have a
studio where I work with Nike and puma
and I'm still like in the corporate
world you got clients and doing your own
thing exactly so I'm still in the world
that's a cool approach so I have these
three pillars that I'm always constantly
doing it was the first CU I know that's
complete fulfillment for me and then I'm
you know the the hardest part for me
is is is really this is the for
especially for my brand like my brand me
and then your out there and trophy
hunting my brand is the pr side of it is
like doing what about what about
bringing in somebody we've brought I
we've we've tried and we're still in the
process yeah because I think it's can I
give you a good piece advice on this cuz
I know you're very well and I think I
spent so all of us are paying attention
you know I listen to all of you you're
all doing kind of similar to me it's my
biggest rength too I talk all the time
so people are confused by this 90% of
what I do is listen it's why I'm always
talking I've got so much to observe that
that I want to talk about
the number one way a guy like you on a
brand like yours will win is by spending
a lot of time on social media and seeing
a young kid doing something cool yeah
and then dming her him being like yo I
[__] with this and then them hitting you
up and them viewing you as the it's all
just steps yeah so like you you usually
the mistake that is made is you go for
something that's too professional yeah
they have the resume or you they used to
work with Nike or they [__] with you
know they did a thing for spray ground
that you but they were a team of 80 no
no you need a [__] Scrapper right
yeah yeah we need someone to call hyp
beast and tell them to put our [__] on
but first but first you need a kid who's
the 17-year-old us yeah or the
22-year-old US who even knows the upand
cominging best writer at H High Beast
like she and he lives it you're either
of the culture or you're not whatever
culture that is not when I say culture
obviously that's now more urban hip-hop
but I'm talking about any culture sports
music cooking like you're like I'll use
I'll make this even more prominent
you're either knowledgeable like me with
wine I grew up in wine I worked in it
from 14 to 34 from 14 to 34 from 16 to
34 I knew everything I knew every writer
I knew every wine I knew everything I
now know an unbelievable amount of about
wine I'm passionate about it I keep up
on it I don't know [__] compared to the
[__] 30-year-old me the 30-year-old
me knew
everything and you this will make sense
to all of you once you're at of
something you're out of it if you go out
to the hottest clubs in New York and la
and Vegas every night you know
everything that's happening you take a
step away and you come back six months
later and everything's [__] different
right whatever it is boy you know this
you're an anr like you you you know I
know you well enough to know like
there's some six months when you know
everything and there's some six months
when you're busy with some [__] with
your family or you got [__] that you're
doing for me or we got brown fortunate
or whatever it is and you're like it's
just the way it is what you need to do
is find the kid that really know the the
kid that's like cool I'll get you hype
beast but do you know about street
street and you're like what the [__] is
street street and it's the next hype
Beast right that's who you [__] need
cuz everyone else is going to be [__]
for you that I was about to tell you
like H you have so much more no no no
yeah I was I I know what you're saying I
know what you're saying all right let's
get a question couple things let me
answer the question that the kid had CU
I was excited about this that was in the
chat somebody said tra I see it Trav c21
on Twitch says how can I get financial
help building an app while I live
paycheck to paycheck Trav it's almost
impossible most people don't get funded
it's very hard there's a lot of issues
with it but right now money is expensive
even the people that go to Stanford are
having a harder time raising Capital
because people with money are getting 5%
interest on their money why are they
going to risk it on some [__] startup
money got valuable it's the hardest time
to get money right now but Trav let me
tell you why I picked your question we
are moments away I want everyone to hear
this we are moments away from all of us
building apps in one hour using
AI the fact that all of us are going to
be able to build websites and apps using
AI in a year is
bananas that's how much AI is advancing
it will program
applications like I don't want to jump
to the biggest hyperbole I'm not
educated enough to know that we're
really there within the next 24 months
that you can build a like a really solid
iPhone app in like an hour but it's not
as far away as people think and I would
say for all of you with the million
other things that you have to be focused
on for your business this thing that's
emerging called AI is like a real
[__] beast and so um it's going to be
it's going to be pretty exciting and I
see everyone reacting to it it's going
to be a big deal it's going to change
the world the way the internet did and I
hope everyone is actually now that we're
going into the holidays I hope everyone
during the holidays you know how the
holidays are there's downtime along with
all the stuff you have to do maybe one
night when you're drinking some cocoa or
some tequila like maybe maybe you spend
two three hours and start googling
getting educated about AI listening to a
podcast watch a YouTube show it's time
nobody in this community or at this
table can go into 2024 and not know
anything about AI it's to here so
something to keep in mind as well for
all of us all right let's grab a pack of
cards these are my be friends this is my
Pokemon meets
Marvel universe that I launched in nft
form another new technology but also now
in physical form I want here's how we're
playing the friends card game you're
going to open this pack and I need you
to look at all three four all four
characters and pick the character that
most speaks to you and most represents
you okay I got
mine good ladies first what do you
got I just you TR the
malti because of the way it phys the way
it looks or because of who the character
is no I don't know get the different one
I feel the car is different yes it's a
rare card that's a valuable card you
pull the best card out of all of us so
that's good
I all right what do you got my friend
you locked in oh I got the penguin why
um I I just resonated with the penguin I
don't know I just think they're they're
I think that's a by the way I think it's
a puffin oh it's a the name is it a
puffin oh it's a oh it is a puffin okay
well this thing the bird I buffin in
versus visual list respect my man I
picked uh macro micro just cuz that's
how I kind of work I'm always like
looking afar but then I like being in
the details at the same time it's funny
this is one of my favorite like weird
characters like it's not super popular
we have 283 it's a weird name the
character is called macro micro it's 2
be's but it's how I work too I think I
think people that win I I did a k Swiss
sneaker collaboration and I called the
clouds and dirt I think the people that
are in the clouds dreaming ambition
right and can equally stay in the dirt
humble work
ethic still in it like we talked about
that's why I made M micro macro I think
you know a lot of this is I'm going to
make children's books and things of that
nature and I think some people just
dream and are delusional and don't put
in the work and I think a lot of other
people just work and are and actually my
biggest fear right now in the world is
like people don't dream they've believed
all the negativity in the world they're
like this whole thing that's going on
now with Gen Z kids where they're trying
to tell these gen Z kids that they can't
be more successful than their parents
we're going to be the first generation
not as success it's it's terrible
propaganda it's terrible propaganda
you're telling a generation of kids and
a lot of them believe
it and it's devastating to me yeah a lot
just see through the [__] though too
yeah yeah they do and those are the ones
who are going to win the problem is more
don't right yeah that's what I spend my
time looking at analyzing scaled human
behavior more don't more do think that
it's over like like as like I love this
whole meme of like like gen Z telling
Boomers you [__] up the world go and
read a history book and see what Boomers
said to their
grandparents right the [__] do you think
Boomers grew up with two Wars Global
backto back world wars insane yeah as if
there's just too much negativity in the
world and they've got us fighting over
everything as if religion race and
gender was not enough to divide us now
they're teaching the kids that we have
to divide on Generations gen Z versus
Millennials and Millennials versus
Boomers like we keep stacking the table
with more things to not love each other
versus just looking at each other and
saying we're all team human I [__]
love you the ogs were always always the
most inspirational though for me at
least like they were always the people
that were like even though I didn't do
it like here's a pathway or here's stuff
that you can know about it's all just
exposure experience this this is
mainstream media loving to use like
analytics to tell kids that they can't
be as wealthy as their parents which is
ludicrous do you know many [__]
20-year-olds make more money than their
parents do right now because of the
world there's un we've in fact it's the
Reversed never in the history of time
could teenagers make more money than
their parents but because of the way the
internet works there are let me say nice
and slow for everyone millions of
teenagers around the world who make way
more money than their parents because
they made money on the internet being an
influencer or selling [__] or D so like
they're getting sold this [__] yeah
and meanwhile the reality is the ones
that don't succumb to the [__] are
actually trans like
transcending success for youth that
we've never seen before
please I feel like for me it's the new
era I don't know like I think I think
the history you know I always used to
ask my grandma and everything all the
history in Argentina how everything was
changing and I feel like before when you
didn't used to have you know like the TV
or didn't used to have the cover
everything was changing but when they
era make the change fast now I feel like
we are all learning and everything is
going fast so of course the teenager
getting faster like even the Tik Tok
everything I feel like it's something
like we afraid but also if you think our
kids me thinking with Rio he's two years
old and sometimes I'm like afraid
because yeah like the new technology you
know he don't need to do the homework
nothing but also if he don't really
understand that he will never you know
go to the Future and get in better and
better so how you balance that how you
don't lose you know the part of the
floor but also you know keep the reality
you need to jump in that train I
couldn't agree with you more the you
said the most important word balance we
are living in the greatest era of not
balance it's all
extremism everyone is fighting from left
to right on these things and they think
by going further they're going to bring
the other people over but what we're
doing is going further apart parents you
said another thing parents are
afraid they love these little ones so
much they're afraid and the world is
selling fear
yeah every kid used to be outside 40
years ago and then the news covered
kidnapping 24/7 and then everybody put
their kids inside yeah [__] I walk to
school in kindergarten of me too I walk
to school in kindergarten grew up
outside like like you know and so like
you're absolutely right balance is the
key the problem
is we are in an era right now where we
are the furthest thing from balance I
also think people need I maybe they're
teaching this at school but it's like
the critical thinking it's just like
problems solving I feel like is at a low
where it's like people are learning very
distinct skills and they know how to do
one thing but they don't know how to
like problem solve or do anything so I'm
seeing a lot of especially younger
people who are getting more traction and
being a little bit more uh successful
and fast-paced because they're able to
like problem solve and not just be like
oh I don't know how to do that so I
Googled it didn't work YouTube didn't
show anything so I guess it's wrong I'll
do it the other way and it's just like
we didn't have that we had to figure it
out and it's just cuz you wanted to do
that if I had this technology oh my God
separation that is my thing like you
know like I always as a mom we know the
dads really think on the kids but the
mom sorry but are the moms and we always
think and for me it's like I get that
part but also I feel like they can even
learn more so again how to balance
because now they can fix with the phone
yeah of course and it's like easy for
them but they can learn more so where
they it I feel like it's a new well well
it's a new era because we were all
taught to memorize information
information is worthless it's at our
fingertips and with AI even the ability
to process the information is about to
become worthless my biggest thing is if
we could just get all the moms and dads
around the world to focus on building a
kid's
self-esteem that is going to be the game
the game is not going to be like get
good grades good grades [__] you how
many people we're all grown now what
happened with all our valedictorians
what happened to all the kids you grew
up with that had great grades was that a
my thing that was always confusing to me
is there are plenty valedictorians and
people that got good grades that had
great lives and this the problem was
there was also just as many that didn't
so getting good grades was not a direct
correlation to happiness or financial
success to me like what what like we've
got to get the conversation going to
self-esteem the issue right now is most
kids are
insecure well my mom is a teacher she
says that the biggest problem in school
was like with phone yes with air drop
and everything they used to send
pictures how went vital and how much
they struggled the kids with problems
yeah that was something that my mom
always says so I agree with you with the
self-esteem but also to be
present something like more than
selfesteem with that are like me I work
so hard but when I'm with my kid I'm
present I'm analyzing him yeah for sure
I will tell you this though to your
point a lot of kids say to me this is a
very common DM I'll get from a
15-year-old Gary what do I do here my
parents keep yelling me to be present
meanwhile they're not
present like they're all talking [__]
like be present be respectful and every
time I try to talk to them they're on
their [__] phone right the hypocrisy
like I've literally been in my own home
with other parents who are yelling at me
that technology is bad cuz I'm in the
business and then giving their then
their kid comes but we're having a good
time drinking wine and they give their
kid the iPad so they hush away like
literally they can't even see the
hypocrisy they're literally actively
having a conversation with me that
technology is Bad the kid comes over
they're having a good time so they give
the iPad and go run off Johnny go play
yeah it's hypocrisy at scale all day
yeah he's the easy way look I think I
think the the biggest issue is you know
I see exactly parents are the least
present some are some aren't my big
thing is we've just become incredibly
from parents it makes sense but the
world has become incredibly focused on
telling people what to do versus
focusing on what they
do it's become a national Pastime to
point fingers everybody's got to judge
about
everybody what we used to do to
celebrities we now do to everybody yeah
at scale everyone's being judged which
is why everyone's all [__] up it's
very true anyway let's switch it to a
good note what are you most excited
about before we get out of here what is
like most got you jazzed as we go into
2024 what are you most excited
about me so much first please about mom
that I always say that is important
thing for me
is talking and every day is coming with
something new so funny yeah three three
is like a different like two to three is
like yeah it's going to be awesome for
you that for me also in the company we
like we really have huge retailers in
Australia but now we getting here in us
too so that would how do people find the
company let's make sure we do that oh
yeah yeah cowder superf food you can
find and in us I sells in the website
Revol aan airan is so [__] that is
like the mecca of Los Angeles now it is
do you know that people literally I know
people that literally go to LA to do
business just so they can go to
airwan like literally actually and think
the smoy that is like
$49 [__] I'll say it they sell $ 49
[__] dollar smoothies and people are
lined up clean eating and they have
Balenciaga collaborations and stuff now
clean eating this is one of the biggest
movements in like like clean eating is
just going to be outrageous like all the
biggest brands in the world in 20 years
people are going to be like what the
what are these Brands they're all
building right now it's about
ingredients not calories and it's going
to be a big deal same with skincare yeah
well we have inest double beauty that is
the colash and the honic acid and but
also my I say my hu like my biggest you
know retail in Australia because in
Australia it's already like that it's
normal yeah if I take like yonic acid in
powder for them it's normal yeah
different Trends in different places
makes sense it's coming my man um just
excited how do they find the brand cuz I
I see a lot of people rocking with what
you're what you're rocking with right
now I saw a lot of comments early on
they want to know where to get on my
Instagram like Marvin X Douglas that's
like my fine Jew like I post most of my
fine jewelry work on there and then I'm
also working on a clothing line right
now um it's kind of like a jewelry meets
clothing um it's for the person that
can't really accessorize themselves it
kind of comes accessorized already so
are you wear is that what you're wearing
like this hat was something I kind of
like sewed together um this is like a
jacket by Stuy but I kind of added pins
so it's funny you could you could grab
it it's right in front of you you see
that devil pin I was yeah they were
showing me earlier and I was like this
is amazing it's funny that you're here
you know pinned out yeah because I
collected everything comic books trading
cards I collected everything but pins
was not something I collected but I
loved making videos on the internet to
show people how to make money at garage
sales and one of the things I did very
well with always was Olympic pins like
you go to garage so you buy just a bunch
of Olympic pins for like 10 bucks and
you could sell them individually for
like 200 bucks so when we did be friends
because there's a Disney element and
Disney is very big in pins we did pins
and they've been huge like for everybody
who's on right now go to eBay type in
vriends pins you'll be shocked at
completed sales it's become a whole
thing and I'm and because of that I'm
now more educated on what you're doing
and what other people doing I feel like
it's a very obvious growth in as
Fashions continues to be a currency of
our Society I think what you're doing is
very real and and going to be a much
bigger macro Trend over the next decade
yeah the yeah the collection Factor
definitely plays a part like um I mean
even with like the cards like I grew up
playing Pokemon and one of the thing
they do in Pokemon is collect badges
which are pins so it's like you know
there's that factor that gives you like
the want and like the need of something
like that so you're you're you're making
clothing where the pins are Incorporated
already yes it's kind of like a a more
affordable version of my jewelry line
too since my fine jewelry is like a
specific price point where does that
what price point is that usually um I
would say ring start about like 4,000 go
up from there and I kind of wanted to
make something that was a bit more
accessible without kind of like tainting
the name of Marvin Douglas you know and
that like it's hard way the way want
[__] up the brand yeah so then um father
of pearl is my it's like a play on
mother of pearl the material but father
of pearl is my clothing brand that I'm
working on with like clothing
accessories and like I said for the
person that doesn't know how to
accessorize himself it kind of comes
with accessories already on it so it
kind of does the work for you um and
it's kind of like like I'm I'm just
excited about that I'm excited about
dropping that project and my vision for
it is like you know there's these like
um destinations like Monaco and like
these rich like you know south of France
like Italy like um that have always been
looked at as like these like destination
you know kind of places for like
vacation Y and El Salvador like where
I'm from it's like never been looked at
as that so it's kind of like me
imagining what El Salvador like what the
clothing in El Salvador would look like
if that was a destination like one of
those Rich destinations that's cool bro
I like that you good for you I love that
thanks my man that's cool yeah I'm I'm
just looking forward to all of the
momentum that that's kind of been built
over the last 18 months for the brand
trophy hunting um it seems like it's
really popping yeah no I see I see a lot
of cool people like rocking yeah no we
have we have a really good following um
the the clothing is amazing in person so
our goal next year is to get it in front
of people so we just did a pop-up shop
with NE and Marcus we're going to do
another one um in January or February
and then kind of move into a small piece
of retail and then hopefully open up our
own stores for you but
yeah final question let me look yeah
final question social media content I
believe social media content is the
primary variable of all three of your
businesses yeah besides you the human
and who you as you operate but from a
marketing standpoint where are you at
with the with social media content how's
it going let's go we'll go backwards
we'll end with ladies this time um how's
it going for you or the brand which
platforms are working what's an enigma
what would you like to be better at
what's the state of the union of your
organic social media which is a deep
passion of mine I I struggle with the
organic side uh just because number one
a lot of the stuff that I work on is top
secret and I can't show anything for 18
months out so like if we do something
with Rihanna I can't show you what it is
I can just say it or whatever so I
struggle with like that and then um I'm
just a perfectionist too so it's like I
like curated things to look nice so I I
kind of overwhelm myself and just end up
like not doing anything yeah I mean I
it's funny my team knows where I sit on
perfectionism I always believe I always
believe that perfectionism is slang for
in security I think people beat them
this goes back to beating yourself up
it's like like look clearly all three of
you have like taste and all that I get
that it's a scill like anything else
that being
said when you're building a
business if if you're not talking it's
not happening right so you know if
you're not posting it's not happening
and it's you have to remember it's
inherently selfish to only judge based
on your opinion even though you're the
lead dog there's many things I put out
into the world that I'm not sure but by
putting it out in the world I'm learning
I may be potentially helping someone
with that might be inspired like there's
things that you've killed that might
have been the piece of content that
inspired a young kid to start their
thing totally so I think sometimes we
think too selfishly about our content
and if we thought more selflessly and
think about who's on the other end yeah
all of a sudden it doesn't have to be
perfect
because you realize this might you were
inspired by people putting out [__]
right so something to think about my man
um with social media it's kind of like
it's it's a struggle for me um I think
the consistency in it like as far as
like posting all the time that you know
I have like things available for sale um
well with the business I think that's
where yeah like the consistency of like
posting that I even have stuff for sale
what about posting stuff that's not for
sale um or what about posting an image
of the individual before it's a pin yeah
so that in general I feel like my
consistency is like doing that like I
capture it I just don't post it why I
that's that's can I give you an Insight
have because I don't think you could
think I believe one of the biggest
reasons someone like you may not post it
is you believe it might not do well and
I think one of the biggest things that
I'm trying to teach entrepreneurs and
friends to think about is their
insecurity of the
algorithm so like you people aren't
posting because they're worried that
it's going to get few views and that may
look bad on
them yeah yeah one of the things I would
love for platforms to do that doesn't
bother me though respect everyone's
different by the way I'm not sure I'm
right I'm fishing here mine's more for
mine more for like sales not like the
likes it's like these are like thousands
of dollar pieces you know and it's like
I what about what about thinking that
90% of what you post shouldn't be about
sales so that's that's the thing too
yeah that's that's a good perspective on
it [__] make that change that's one
of the reasons why I don't post all the
time too though is cuz I don't like
being sales or talk about product see I
hate that I here's a
beer easy ready there's an iconic book
written called jab jab jab right hook it
means give give give and occasionally
ask yeah that's how you should think
about your social give it doesn't have
to be here's a beer it could be story
time with this beer hey designers let me
tell you about my first month by myself
I sold nothing it sucked do you know how
much value that could be for someone who
looks up to you too you're being selfish
no that's good I I've been doing that on
threads
lately the [__] is that about you feel
safe there I don't know you feel see I
think Instagram to me has always just
been like pictures and like no no no I
think you no I'll tell you what is
you're putting Instagram on a pedestal
yeah you're treating it like a [__]
Museum I saw something you did recently
with like where you spoke about Facebook
too and like that one really like me I'm
it's just there's so many people that
still use it Facebook's on [__] fire
and I don't use itm because of my dad
yeah literally it's all the it's it's
because millions of people are by the
way my fastest growing my team will tell
you my fastest growing demo on Facebook
is 21 to 30 it's because it's a feed wow
and people are just happen to be on
there like it's just the people are just
not thinking enough anyway social I'm
learning I'm like okay my fav [__] I
don't have I'm like no me really I'm
really practiced so I I have a team that
helped me on that because for me I leave
my phone like that and I'm like you know
working and other things so and I'm like
I say I'm not really artist so I can
admire both of them how they create you
know how you can create things me I'm
like okay post that you know it's easy I
look I think some of the best content on
the Internet is M preneurs I promise you
it is a powerful subject matter it's
something you need to consider true
inspires a lot of people it's a real
deal like it's super real like there's
an ungodly amount of women there are
hundreds of millions of women out there
who are incredibly on fire
professionally but also Aspire and
dreamed and love being a mom and and I
think it is incredibly hard for dads and
dudes to balance life but when you have
a child come out of you there is a
different [__] relationship it's just
the way it is and I think it's one of
the most important subject matters and I
think you can do a lot of good by
talking about your the ups and the downs
I just think it's compelling content I
think you can help people really do yeah
know and I feel like it's a good moment
that I admire when wom's you know like
are entrepreneur and try to grow because
I know how it is I know like yeah you're
living it like exactly like okay yeah
like it's real here I'm giving the food
but also I'm having a meeting and I'm
changing and I'm going to the airport
and of course the mom fly with the kid
to the airport course the flights are
sometimes not easy and you arrive
directly to the meeting or the modeling
so all of that but I love my life even
if you don't have kid and you're a woman
it's hard everything's hard and by the
way something that's finally coming up
I'm glad dudes are being more vulnerable
too like news alert it's hard being a
human but not when you simplify it back
to loving life the way to love life is
to simplify it me I come back from I was
working in Aspen I arrived like Saturday
11:00 p.m. and Sunday morning I went to
the pool with Rio and after to the ice
cream Museum and I forget about
everything I was laughing so much
enjoying it with him like Monday AO he
goes to pretty school
like got a rhym the Rhythm thank you for
being on you three twitch thank you for
watching keep it on for a second thank
you for watching uh everybody listening
at home love you talk
[Music]
soon